Remember the 2005 coming of age superhero movie
“Sky High?” You won’t believe which actor went
on to become an Academy Award winner. Keep
watching to get the dirt on the entire cast.
Michael Angarano starred in "Sky High" as
Will Stronghold, the son of legendary heroes
The Commander and Jetstream, whose late-blooming
powers land him on the sidekick track at his new
super-school. Angarano was only 18 when
"Sky High" first debuted, but by that
point he'd already made over half a dozen TV
appearances and landed several film roles,
including a spot in Cameron Crowe's
music-themed classic "Almost Famous."
"Sky High" was just the beginning of Angarano's
film career. Over the next decade, he appeared
in more than a dozen films, from "The Forbidden
Kingdom" to "The Stanford Prison Experiment."
He also kept up an impressive television
career with recurring roles in "The Knick,"
"24," "Will & Grace," and "I'm Dying
Up Here." These days, the 33 year old
can currently be seen as a recurring cast
member in the hit NBC drama "This Is Us."
Danielle Panabaker landed the part of plant-loving
Layla in "Sky High," her feature film debut,
just a few years into her acting career. After
the film's release, she spent the rest of the
2000s appearing in films like "Yours, Mine, and
Ours" and the 2009 reboot of "Friday the 13th."
The early 2010s saw Panabaker
in a number of TV series,
most notably "Necessary Roughness"
and FX's western-themed "Justified."
These days, the 34-year-old Panabaker
is best known for her work in the CW's
Arrowverse shows as Caitlin Snow and
her supervillain alter-ego Killer Frost.
She first appeared in the role as a guest star in
the second season of "Arrow," but when CW created
the spinoff show "The Flash," Panabaker joined
as a main cast member. Since then, she's appeared
in multiple episodes of other Arrowverse shows,
like "Supergirl" and "DC's Legends of Tomorrow."
Panabaker has been vocal about her desire
to return to the world of "Sky High."
In 2019, she told the International
Business Times that she would be,
quote, "a thousand percent" interested in
participating in a sequel. She went on to say,
"I'd like to think that maybe
they're teachers at 'Sky High,'
because it's been long enough that
they could go back and teach."
There aren't any solid plans for a sequel
so far, but the door certainly remains open.
Dee Jay Daniels had a prolific career as a
child actor. He got his start on NBC's "In
the House" with LL Cool J, and had a starring
role on "The Hughleys" from 1998 to 2002.
"Sky High" was Daniels' first and only
film role. His character Ethan was part
of the group of sidekicks at the core
of the film, and he finds a way to help
save the day despite his seemingly useless
ability to turn himself into a puddle of goo.
Despite his impressive and hilarious performance,
Daniels struggled to find more work as he got
older. In an extended 2021 interview with Vlad
TV alongside his former co-star D.L. Hughley,
Daniels opened up about his struggles
with acting. Fans were shocked to see
that, over the years, Daniels had
covered his face with several tattoos,
a decision he claimed to have made partially
in response to his lagging acting career.
Daniels also talked about how his career
was further derailed when he was arrested
on suspicion of murder in 2012. It didn't
take long for Daniels to be acquitted,
but the experience left an
impression on him nonetheless.
Nowadays, Daniels is pursuing a rap career, but he
says that he's always open to returning to acting.
Few actors from "Sky High" have kept as busy as
Nicholas Braun, who was just 17 when the film
was first released. Braun told BuzzFeed that he
was with two of his friends when he got the call
that he'd landed the role of Zach in "Sky High,"
and that he couldn't contain his excitement:
"I screamed and yelled… I still feel
that way, though, when I get a part."
If that's the case, Braun has spent a
good amount of time yelling and screaming.
After "Sky High," Braun spent a handful
of years bouncing between television
shows before landing a recurring role on
"10 Things I Hate About You." From there,
he turned his attention to the big screen for
films like "The Stanford Prison Experiment" with
fellow "Sky High" alum Michael Angarano, "How to
Be Single," and "The Perks of Being a Wallflower."
Braun has kept just as busy in recent years,
starring in two major films — "Zola" and
"The Big Ugly" — in 2020 alone. However, Braun
truly broke into the mainstream as fan favorite
character Cousin Greg in HBO's "Succession." As
for what's to come in Braun's still-young career?
"You have to wait and see like everybody
else! But it's awesome, man. It's awesome."
Who could forget Magenta, the shapeshifter
that can only become a guinea pig? Kelly
Vitz's character in "Sky High" had one of
the most memorable powers, and definitely the
most memorable hair style. Magenta was put on the
sidekick track with the film's other protagonists,
and she helped to prove that anyone, no matter
their powers, has the ability to be a hero.
Vitz had a short-lived acting career that began
in 2002 when she made a one-line appearance on
the Disney Channel show "Lizzie McGuire." Her
next role was in "Sky High," and after that
she landed roles in the horror film "Simon Says,"
"Eye of the Dolphin," "Nancy Drew," and "Teenius."
Her final film role was as Ailes
Gilmour in the 2010 film "Leonie."
That same year, Vitz graduated from
the University of -California Berkeley
with a degree in Public Health, leaving the
film industry to pursue other career goals.
Steven Strait was fresh out of high school and
just 18 years old when he joined the cast of
"Sky High" as the aptly named Warren Peace.
"Sky High" was Strait's first feature film,
and only his second professional acting credit
after a guest appearance on "Third Watch" in 2001.
Strait followed up the role with a run of
feature films over the next five years,
which included "The Covenant," "Undiscovered,"
"10,000 B.C.," "Stop-Loss," and "City Island."
Since 2015, Strait has starred in the
SyFy/Amazon Prime series "The Expanse"
as the brave starship captain Jim Holden. In
a December 2020 interview with Geeks of Color,
Strait was asked if he'd ever consider reprising
his role as Warren Peace if Disney revived
"Sky High" in some way. Strait said that
he's absolutely open to the idea, adding,
"I loved that experience,
and they're awesome people!"
Malika Haqq started acting in commercials and
TV shows at a young age. By the early 2000s,
she was used to the grind of
auditions and faceless casting
directors — so much so that when she and
her twin sister Khadijah auditioned for
"Sky High," they didn't even realize it
was a feature film. She told E! Online,
"​​We actually thought the movie was going
to go straight to the Disney Channel,
and out of all of those options,
we felt so blessed and overwhelmed
to learn that [...] 'Sky High'
was going to be our first film."
Haqq has starred in a few more feature films
in the years since "Sky High": most recently,
she appeared in the 2016 film "Definitely
Divorcing." However, Haqq is best known
for her recurring role in the reality TV series
"Keeping Up with the Kardashians." She's been part
of the show since Season 2, and she was a main
cast member on the spinoff series "Dash Dolls."
Khadijah Haqq McCray's big break also came when
she was cast in "Sky High," and her career since
has had a similar trajectory to her sister's as
well. Just one year later, the two went on to
star in the film "ATL." McCray's last scripted
acting role was in an episode of Kevin Hart's
"Real Husbands of Hollywood" in 2013, but like
her sister, she was featured on "Keeping with the
Kardashians" and co-starred on "Dash Dolls." In
2010, she married NFL defensive end Bobby McCray,
and in a January 2021 Instagram post, the
pair announced a new addition to their family.
Jake Sandvig was only 19 when "Sky High"
arrived in theaters, and it marked his second
feature film. His first, "The Story of Us,"
starred Bruce Willis and Michelle Pfeiffer,
and it came out when Sandvig was just 13 years
old. Despite making appearances in a few TV
episodes in the meantime, it was after "Sky High"
that his acting career really started to heat up.
Sandvig had recurring roles on
"Twenty Good Years" and "Cracking Up."
His next major film role came in 2010's
"Easy A," and a year later he wrote and
starred in the film "A Bag of Hammers."
After that, Sandvig returned to television,
moving from "Weeds" to "CSI" to USA's
"Rush." His most recent roles were in 2017,
when he appeared in "Bridal Boot Camp" and
"Hometown Hero" on the Hallmark Channel.
Will Harris followed up his role as Speed in
"Sky High" with two low-budget features in 2007:
"On Broadway" and "Awaken the Dead." After
that, he spent much of his time acting in
some of the most popular shows of the decade, such
as "CSI," "Friday Night Lights," and "Community."
Harris' pace has never slowed down. While
continuing to make guest appearances on a
variety of shows throughout the 2010s, he's
also lent his talents to the films "In Time"
and "Sharon 1.2.3." He's had a busy 2021: he
made a guest appearance on ABC's "The Rookie,"
and he took part in the crime drama "No Man of
God" and the horror film "Shot in the Dark."
Mary Elizabeth Winstead, who played Gwen
in "Sky High," is probably the film's most
recognizable cast member that isn't Kurt Russell.
Though she began her acting career in 1997,
"Sky High" was only Winstead's third feature
film. Her role in the film gave Winstead
the opportunity to display her range, from
kind-hearted classmate to diabolical villain.
Winstead followed up "Sky High" with
"Final Destination 3," and horror
has been part of her wheelhouse ever since.
She's made appearances in "Abraham Lincoln:
Vampire Hunter" and "10 Cloverfield
Lane," as well as iconic pop culture
films like "Scott Pilgrim vs.
the World" and "Birds of Prey."
Winstead's most recent leading
role was as the titular assassin
in the Netflix action film "Kate." While
speaking with Collider about the movie,
Winstead took a moment to reflect on
her beloved performance in "Sky High,"
and speculated about what role her character
would take in a sequel film, saying,
"[Gwen is] still operating
as a supervillain, for sure."
"I went through puberty twice for this?"
Kevin Heffernan had already starred in "Super
Troopers" by the time he got a part in "Sky
High," and he put his comedic experience
to excellent use by bringing school bus
driver Ron Wilson's unabashed excitement
to life. Just like the audience watching
"Sky High," Ron is an enthusiastic fan of
all things superhero. Getting to "drive"
the next generation of heroes to Sky High
every morning is a dream come true for Ron,
and by the end of the film, he gets
his own opportunity to be a hero.
In the years since "Sky High," Kevin Heffernan has
continued putting his talents to work in comedies
of all stripes. He's made guest appearances
in some of the biggest sitcoms of the past two
decades — "Curb Your Enthusiasm," "How I Met Your
Mother," and "Veep," to name a few — and his film
roles, which include "Strange Wilderness" and "The
Babymakers," have had a similarly comedic bend.
Currently, fans can catch up with
Heffernan on truTV's "Tacoma FD."
He created the series with
the help of Steve Lemme,
and the two of them lead the show as Chief
Terry McConky and Captain Eddie Penisi.
As one of the few adults cast in "Sky High,"
Jim Rash already had over a decade of acting
experience under his belt when he signed on to
play Mr. Grayson and his alter ego, Stitches.
Most notably, from 2002 through 2006,
he had a recurring role as Fenton on
"That '70s Show." Though he'd maintained
a steady stream of roles up to that point,
Rash's career was in many
ways just getting started.
Four years after "Sky High," Rash joined the
cast of "Community" as Dean Craig Pelton,
a role that he would continue playing throughout
the show's entire six-season run. He's also made
non-stop appearances in TV shows and movies for
the past decade: most recently, he's been the
voice of Flix in "Star Wars Resistance" and the
Riddler in the animated "Harley Quinn" series.
Rash is also the only member of the "Sky High"
cast to have won an Academy Award so far,
having received the Best Adapted Screenplay
Oscar for "The Descendants" in 2012.
Dave Foley is probably best known for the
work he did before "Sky High." Foley and
Kevin McDonald formed sketch comedy troupe
"The Kids in the Hall" in 1984, and their TV
show of the same name ran from 1988 to 1995. "The
Kids in the Hall" is set for a revival in 2022,
but Foley has kept himself plenty busy
in the years since it went off the air.
In addition to starring in the occasional
feature film, Foley has spent a majority of
his time making guest appearances
on everyone's favorite TV shows.
He's taken on live-action series like "It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia" and "Veep,"
as well as animated shows like "Robot
Chicken" and "Dan Vs." In 2021 alone,
Foley has made guest appearances in "Young
Sheldon," "Call Your Mother," "Superstore,"
and "The Morning Show." There isn't a style of
comedy that Foley can't seem to handle perfectly.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.